in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatments alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and joining me
today to talk about the sweet things in
life and of course about nutrition is
Professor Hans geo cues from the German
Institute of human nutrition in Potsdam
today outside our usual studio setting
welcome professor used to in good shape
why is it that most human beings are
just crazy about sweets I think it's
because of the evolution it appears to
be an evolutionary benefit an advantage
to taste sweet foods which signals
energy but nowadays this evolutionary
advantage seems to have turned against
us sugar makes us fat yes why is that
it's not the sugar itself it's the
combination of sugar and fat and taste
enhancers that is the main problem
these foods do not satiate and that's
why we have a positive energy balance if
we eat too much of that and then we'll
gain weight so if we start eating sugar
we just can stop that's not for
everybody the case I would say again the
problem is the combination of fat and
sugar leading to not satiating foods and
what about the health risks of sugar
that's sugar cause diabetes for instance
it does indirectly if it leads to weight
increase there is fat accumulation in
the liver and in the pancreas which
causes diabetes and sugar is blamed for
a lot of other things to do like like
even maybe causing cancer is any truth
to that again there are indirect effects
so cancer is associated with overweight
and the overweight might be
produced by sugar in in combinations
it's not the sugar itself which causes
the disease but it's the effect of his
operating current yes the World Health
Organization has drastically reduced its
recommendation about the sugar intake
that we should take every day 225 grams
per day which is roughly this amount of
sugar cubes here in this this thing and
this is what we actually eat every day
so you see it's it's a lot of more it's
this a realistic thing that we restrict
ourselves to this kind of amount of
sugar it is very difficult one could
even say it's unrealistic simply because
sugar is everywhere in every foods we
buy and things where you wouldn't expect
it like what like breakfast cereals or
cabbage or dried tomatoes and what about
soda and dreams I mean we all know that
soda is full of sugar and what about
orange juice there's a lot of sugar in
orange juice as well isn't it yes it's
the same amount as in sodas but
apparently one doesn't tend to drink as
much of the orange juice as of a soda so
it's just the amount which counts or is
in the end it comes down to the amount
of calories you consume per day and if
you cut down for instance the fat then
you can afford to eat more sugar and if
I look at this at those sugar cubes and
we have to take into account that I'm
eating apples and bananas or is it just
the industrial sugar which I add to know
the waho meant only the industrial sugar
okay their various forms of sugar
sucrose glucose fructose all the same or
is some form more dangerous roughly all
the same with one exception there is an
effect of fructose
it may cause insulin resistance but only
at higher doses where she wouldn't
normally reach petit Kate Thompson from
Canada has read that artificial
sweeteners could cause cancer is that
true we don't have any proof for that so
I would say artificial sweeteners as we
have them are safe okay yeah that's good
to know because in the report we saw
that many many people want to lose
weight with the use of artificial
sweeteners but sometimes it just can't
happen so they don't lose weight why is
that well the most likely explanation is
that these persons compensate by eating
more of something else and I guess
that's the case so they they eat
something sweet and then they want to
eat something else because I'm more
sweet yes well the the regulation of the
energy balance is very very strict and
if you leave out some calories
uj-- compensate by eating something else
if you don't pay attention to what you
eat okay we got a question from
Nicaragua Valentin amantha asked if
stevia is the better form of artificial
sweeteners stevia is a natural product
and it is said that it is superior to
other sweeteners because the taste is
better however it's not the totally
identical with a taste of sucrose there
is a minor flavor that distinguishes in
it and what about honey just just using
honey for sweetness is it better than
sugar I don't see any medical advantage
of honey it's biochemically identical to
other sugars and I don't see any
advantage in health in terms of health
just the taste perhaps yeah many people
depend on processed food for the daily
diet and they're full of sugar and
sugars so how can you can you in void it
first of all you shouldn't only look at
the sugar it's also the fat and it's the
salt and other things that enhance the
taste so these ready-made products are
one of the reasons for the obesity
epidemic what you need to do is you need
to be conscious about it try to avoid
overeating try to eat many say da ting
products like cereals and vegetables so
you don't need to actually look at the
package and see if there's sugar in it
just just take your weight you should
look at the package and see whether it's
a kind of dangerous combination but you
have no chance of calculating your daily
calories and even your energy balance by
calculating so this is how you try to
avoid sugar if you just bet you just
take your body weight I would just
regularly take my body weight and see
whether there is a trend towards
increasing and then I would cut down on
something and and you still snack and
eat sweets yourself not on a regular
basis I'm pretty conscious about what I
eat so like what cereals vegetables
fruits and only rarely fast food great
so now you can go to the katene here and
eat some sweets or eat some fruits
you